la gratuité des transports publics en
ile de france c'était une promesse
d'anne hidalgo candidate à la mairie de
paris
c'est maintenant une promesse de sa
protégée audrey pulvar candidate
socialiste à la présidence de la région
ile de france rejoindrait ainsi
dunkerque montpellier où même les
communes franciliennes de levallois est
plutôt qu'ils ont mis en place des bus
municipaux gratuit en plus du réseau
régional
en 2008 valérie pécresse avait commandé
un rapport sur le coût de cette gratuité
pour la collectivité qui s'élèverait à
2,5 milliards d'euros par an alors
comment financer ce manque à gagner est
bien la candidate
audrey pulvar a la réponse la création
de nouvelles taxes sur les commerces sur
les fortunes immobilières ou encore sur
les transports polluants
alors où est le problème juridique ici
bien juridiquement ça pose problème
parce que c'est un problème qui remonte
en plus de ça à la révolution française
et bien c'est le parlement et lui seul
qui créent les impôts
conséquence la région ne peut pas créer
de nouvel impôt et si elle est élue
audrey pulvar devra demander au
parlement de bien vouloir le faire pour
elle ce qui en l'état actuel des
équilibres politiques
on va pas se mentir est hautement
improbable alors c'est vrai que la
région gère quelques taxes la taxe sur
les cartes grises par exemple dont elle
peut modifier le taux ou encore la tei
ces po1 que vous payez à la pompe
mais audrey pulvar précise bien qu'elle
ne veut pas toucher à ces taxes voilà
donc une promesse qui risque de se
perdre en cours de route et de faire une
victime la crédibilité des responsables
politiques